luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey hey and welcome
back to my channel it is of course supposed
to buy blockbuster dollars there's links
everywhere it's powered by plus capital the
hey what's going on can you hear me okay yeah yeah
can you hear me yeah perfect perfect yeah we were
um you caught me listening to the congressional
hearing and um live on clubhouse with a group
of uh of people who are interested in regulatory
uh kind of stuff and so we're just doing a little
feedback on that but uh you pinged me and said
you needed uh someone to fill in so here i am
uh i'm gonna pass on lunch pass on regulatory
feedback no i love that well firstly i appreciate
your time i've called you gigger chad i don't
know if you've noticed but um i've called you
gig a chad because like what kind of gig what
kind of person has to be only a giga child that
can literally just come online like that no i love
it i really appreciate it thank you so much um but
what is going on with this congressional hearing
i had no idea um obviously i'm in the uk i didn't
know this was happening so give me the lowdown
yeah it was a big deal like a lot of us had been
um kind of feeling a bit of doom and gloom about
it because we had the big china move to ban mining
i kind of miscalculated the scope of it i thought
it may have been just like a shuffling of the deck
and and kind of weeding out some bad actors but
it appears that it's far-reaching um that affected
the market a little bit uh negatively and then
we knew that this hearing that maxine waters was
putting up here uh today um the title of which
was like america is on fire is cryptocurrency
gonna burn down the world like really negative um
i expected a lot of esg energy flood tether flood
um and then tax confusion and regulatory
confusion the recurrent word of cryptocurrency
versus bitcoin uh an attack on proof-of-work
mining you know all of those topics came up
but i think it was a net win um for
bitcoin in particular i thought the
the um the people who were testifying
as witnesses did a fair job and i think
some of the uh uh the congress men and congress
women said ridiculously foolish things comparing
investments in cryptocurrency to playing the
california lottery for example and recommending
that as an alternative it's like ridiculous
that dogecoin is a threat to the us dollars
is laughable uh that ethereum is a
threat to bitcoin it's ludicrous so
uh look my blood sugar's a little low but
my energy is always there if i collapse
just send call now it's fine no it's fine i got
you i got you it's cool but yeah it's really odd
because i heard um the other day somebody who i
don't know who it was i'm not gonna oh maybe it
was elizabeth warren i don't know i'm not american
but i think it was elizabeth warren that was sort
of that was of using bitcoin and doge in the same
sentence saying how they're a threat and they're
bad for the environment and that um you know it's
gambling and it's dangerous and it's unregulated
and i was just not thinking how can you even
put doge and bitcoin in the same sentence like
i know i for one love to sort of like joke about
doge like i still i still think doge is hilarious
and i love it from that standpoint it's
dumb yeah so for those listening on audio
um jason has just written um it's done on a
piece of paper but it is but i don't understand
what what what was the point in this congressional
hearing why did it start i i need background
well i mean these hearings are to explore uh
regulatory positions um and to introduce the
discussion uh to the american people and to other
congress people who will be voting on topics you
know there's an agenda behind all of this believe
me all of these folks are bought and paid for
by industries so you're talking about that's
awesome yeah it's awful so you're talking about
some of the most regulated and entrenched
institutions that have built america oil
power energy uh the finance system and here you
know bitcoin kind of uh it it has so many um
relevant i wouldn't even say implications it
it crosses so many boundaries and i think it
catches people off guard if you approach bitcoin
superficially um you may you may not uh respect it
but if you spend any time with it and uh like
i challenge your your listeners to listen to
gigi's book 21 lessons it's like the only bitcoin
book that i can finish at like 1.2 or 1.4 x
speed in like two hours and i listen to it all the
time when i drive uh to my second home i really
enjoy it uh the 21 lessons by gigi it's fantastic
and it really it just lights my brain on fire in
regards to um you know how important bitcoin is
well what about it it's good because i'm finishing
up a book right now and i'm a bit terrified
to let the world see it so go on oh please
i wouldn't even do it justice i mean it takes
you through all of the relevant topics of like
the monetary system why bitcoins bitcoin what
mining is it gets into some technical stuff
because gigi is an engineer not an economist
uh he says he's non-technical but the book is
uh sort of technical but it it talks about
things in such a way that's so inspiring to
someone like me who who tries to uh be a bit
cognitively diverse in my own kind of approach
to things i'm not a technical in terms of coding
but i i i do like science and math and i enjoy
pressure testing some of the things that
are going on like proof of work mining
it really bothers me when i hear people talk about
bitcoin mining as some type of like uh program
that's random randomizing numbers and competing
for a reward and that's what it is so it's a giant
waste of computational energy this huge power hog
that does absolutely nothing right that's not what
it does like i wish people would step back and
i'm i'm asking technical people to challenge this
bitcoin proof of work mining is an elegant
timestamp server because that's really what
satoshi created it's keeping things in order
transactions in order and then it places it in
the block and then and then broadcast that in a
decentralized way where everyone has the proof of
time time that's what bitcoin mining does it
maintains the timing of this giant timestamp
server and why wouldn't that take energy give me
a break yeah wait no absolutely give me a break
okay so he's showing dumb again no you're
100 right and you know i've been i've been
writing so much about this recently and
i'm writing about the difficulty adjustment
and i think you know everybody you know buys
bits people buy bitcoin but not everybody who
buys understands the intricacies or the elegance
of the technology and um you know everything you
know you brought up china and everything that's
gone on there it doesn't matter of course like we
were saying you know it's bigger than we thought
and i think i saw um i think it's zach rowell um
his last name correctly he was saying that
um you know you can't just plug an asic
into a volcano you can't just plug in like
the infrastructure to mine takes time and so
you know obviously this will have an effect
on the network but the network will survive
because of these these delicate intricacies things
like the difficulty adjustment will just kick in
um and i i'm absolutely with you and i think that
i'm actually happy that the fight has come up
i like it because i personally have learned so
much about it more people are learning about
it it wouldn't have given everybody a reason
particularly nick carter he did a great job
um of explaining this topic you know it just
wouldn't if we continued going the way we were
going it really wouldn't um and i've won i've
learned so much especially about the fact like
you said everything uses energy but it's about
whether it's worth it you know in terms of all the
benefits of bitcoin i mean obviously it's worth
it i i i tend to find it offensive for someone to
have energy i mean look stop using a blow dryer
right not really christmas lights yeah and again
it's so dumb like this is a really like that's
the the theme of the day like these discussions
they're dumb they're it's just so dumb to talk
about like who should use power for what and like
i even tweeted today climate crisis
laugh out loud like i'm i wait wait
yeah just have a question okay so like this is
obviously such a big thing um i mean do you think
they're like like bitcoin aside do you think that
the climate crisis do you think we're there's doom
coming and the world is ending and we're all about
to go underwater are you like a greta thundberg
lover or no there's no climate no i'm i just sit
here and i listen to people like oh it's so hot
because of carbon and like and people we're
destroying the planet like i'm not sure about that
like i'm just not sure about that i i don't
know if there's a climate crisis or do you
do you support that that that bitcoin mining is
destroying the planet no certainly not um but
you know like in terms of the wider conversation
what i think is really interesting and somebody
hurts all cans or destroying the others no i'm
asking you do you feel no of course not okay you
think that the combustion engine and our cars are
are destroying the earth like it's going to cause
the end of civilization like do you feel like
that's that's going to happen i mean not really no
not particularly but what i want to say though
about this topic which is interesting because
somebody actually pointed this out to me they said
that um so when we were younger i don't know what
it was like in the states but when i was younger
in england um in school we were the narrative we
were taught is global warming okay global warming
oh yeah yeah oh nice you got your uk possible but
you didn't grow up you didn't grow up here you
grew up over there you always try and say that
you're english but you're just not and trust me
you support man you if you were mancunian you'd
be a whole different vibe if you were actually
mancunian you were american through anyway back
to what i was saying so um my job is to distract
you so yeah i know you're doing a good job of it
i've done a good job of it no so when we were
younger in the uk where you were not um we were
always taught about global warming but now the
catchphrase and the slogan has changed now it's
the climate emergency i mean for me the fact that
you have like marketing campaigns behind things
um is always very concerning i mean i'm not gonna
get into um you know the good old pandemic i can't
be bothered but i'll just say you know if things
are that deadly you shouldn't need a marketing
campaign behind it yeah i i have unfortunately
and i don't know when the us um it was recent
the last 10 15 years the united states made
it legal for them to launch psychological
operations against its citizens we've used psyops
which was like a special forces military thing
uh you know around the world during times of
war but it was made legal uh to use against
u.s citizens and and i now have challenged a lot
of my own beliefs you know um when it comes to
these big headlines climate change ufos um well
all this wait i believe in ufos i believe yeah
but i'm just saying like now like all bets are
off because the government's using psychological
operations against its citizens i i i don't know
what's going on i'm questioning everything now
and trying to kind of primary source verify it
like uh if any ufo uh or any aliens are listening
stop by pick me up let's do this i want
to know if you're real i'm real let's rock
jason do you have do you have um a favorite
conspiracy theory because i heard one which
i'll share with you after which was honestly
so cool i i don't i i'm not a huge conspiracy
theorist um you know i've read beyond a
pale horse and uh you know i love the uh
bilderberg group guys you know it's always fun
to think there's like a group of people in a very
sultry environment with big leather chairs and
and drinking like cocktails that you know like
like the elite like the yeah yeah illuminati
you're going uh you know raise the price of oil
yeah yeah and they and that's the comics
double masks yeah let's wear two masks uh
you've had your vaccine not good enough
there's delta delta we need to wear your masks
no i'm with you i'm so with you no i like that i i
don't know i don't know like i was just like right
yeah yeah right yeah what what's your favorite
conspiracy theory no wait so i there's definitely
a table with a group of probably men where
they sit at maybe like one woman or something
and they say this will be the agenda no women
really no they have like that they have like this
like a periodic table of elements right and they
have a wheel on it they like spin and they got
a thorium and then they do some things you
know like that no there are no women in this
okay fair fare okay maybe i'll be the first
woman you know diversity cocktail waitress
oh yeah yeah no but i'll be the first woman at the
table like diversity come on okay so this is my
one okay so i saw this on tick tock of all places
i love tech talk and um basically they were saying
you know that we're taught that the earth is made
up of several layers you've got like the core and
the mantra the the mantle and the lava and all
this stuff anyway so apparently this is actually
only a hypothesis nobody has actually physically
seen this with their own eyes like this is just
the best hypothesis we have right now and so we
go with it and we teach it but somebody basically
came up with this whole theory that there
could be this entire civilization living within
earth like literally with and as as if like earth
is actually hollow yeah um and i loved that and
apparently there was enough research to support
it but as if i've seen the research i haven't um
but loved it no i i think that's a great a great
conspiracy another thing that i only recently
was thinking about and um what's the guy's name
eric weinstein he actually needed it and it was
just by coincidence i had been listening
to gosh what's the name of the book it
is called uh cosmic queries by um what's the
dude's name tyson neil tyson degrassi and um
from listening to that book i was sitting
at the ocean and i was like you know what
it's so egocentric to think and i
think it's egotistical or egocentric
right so egotistical to think that aliens would
be just interested in humans right follow me here
giant ocean teeming with life all of that life
can communicate with each other and has giant
ecosystems right we're a small component
of all the things on earth so if another
alien like civilization zoomed to earth why
wouldn't they be interested in like ants like
ants lift 15 times their body weight and create
sophisticated civilizations or bees why wouldn't
they spend their time with bees why does it always
have to be like probing a human in the rectum
lovely thank you for the picture really appreciate
that um but like forget forget like what could
be on planet earth i definitely think that there
is stuff out there so in some ways it is sort of
egotistical to think that they would even be
interested in us anyway um but basically when
i called you a giga chad in the title next to
that i don't know if you've seen but i also said
is bitcoin going to the moon is the super cycle
still happening now you have a prediction for
this year yeah yeah yeah you're you're all
for the super cycle aren't you well i don't
know if it's super cycle but i do think we're a
worse solid six figures by the end of this year
solid six figures yeah i mean right now whoops
bitcoin is thir you can't see it
thirty-four no i can't see it oh no yeah
right uh yeah yeah like we're we're six figures
by the end of this year without a doubt in my
opinion like i i think and it could be like north
of two hundred thousand by the way yeah this year
okay so can you talk me okay so can you talk
me through um how we're getting there because
i definitely i'm definitely not against it i
feel like we've had our nice fair share of fud
we've managed to survive it china have been [ __
] we've managed to you know survive that so so
how do we get to 200k by let's say december or
november that's my what max kaiser says doesn't
he yeah it's like uh if you've ever read sun
tzu and sun tzu speaks about um momentum and
how you generate force right and it's like
drawing a bow back and the harder you pull it back
the more force and momentum you actually
release once you do that and i feel that
we're getting to kind of an apex position
with bitcoin you have energy fund you have
institutional interest you have all of the banks
aping into positions you have the first country uh
calling bitcoin legal tender you're going to
have a number of countries follow suit those
countries then that are um that have made bitcoin
legal tender are doing interesting things doing
countries one country el salvador air dropping
150 million dollars of bitcoin on its citizens
thirty dollars per citizen it does something
very interesting one it clarifies the fact that
you can buy fractions of bitcoin too people in
a digital environment three they've made it uh
they've made it legal to settle debts and i think
you're going to see a number of central american
and south american countries and i know for you
u.s listeners you don't understand geography
uh central america is not like the middle of the
united states there's a whole segment of the world
that has other countries and then south america is
not miami it's actually a whole another continent
it's really cool and there are countries there
too and these countries do other things other
than what americans do so anyway all of that
momentum you know that bow being pulled back
right the crack two it's gonna be released that's
going to send bitcoin uh up up and away and um
regulation is going to be favorable taxation's
going to be favorable the uk is bad like they
have a lot of bad things going on their teeth
are bad the weather's bad it's pissing me great
you're i don't even know if you really are uh
english because i don't you got good teeth but
a lot of the teeth are not good they got bad teeth
i don't know what happens there it's that crappy
food you guys eat or something to be honest like
that's an actual difference though between brits
and americans like i will take that like when i
went to america last time i was in america i was
like 18 or 19. um everybody had perfect teeth
unbelievable um but wait let's go back let's
go back to el salvador because oh my god it's so
unbelievable um i want to go and i think it will
do so much for the country everybody's like oh
it's so dangerous you don't actually want to go
and perhaps maybe i won't go on my own or maybe
i'll go with a group of people or whatever um but
i think you're a mccormick he does chores i know
i've seen i've seen it's brilliant um but no i
think it's amazing you know mexico doing the
set uh hopefully we'll do something similar
um i mean i do think that it will be not just
from like a financial and economic standpoint but
i think from like a tourist standpoint it will be
so good for the country especially in cleaning it
up right yeah when you were just saying like hey
i'd like to maybe go to salvador someone should
immediately create either a surf camp or a bitcoin
kind of like report right bang and just start this
bitcoin uh tourism going because there's so many
wonderful things like i would love to go to el
salvador and check out the volcanoes and see what
yeah they're mining or you know like it could be
an amazing thing can you do it right you can do it
your time right right you're a businessman you're
always like you're always innovating the president
doesn't follow me he follows peter mccormick
we need to sort that out through you me and peter
need to get on a call that's what needs to happen
and then we'll bring the president in i can't even
i can't even get verified on twitter these guys
they hate me why can't you get verified
on twitter you're always on fox and
things like that no i don't know i don't know i
won't accept it though at this point i officially
renounce any attempt to verify me on twitter yeah
you don't want it not anymore fair enough i don't
think i really wanted it in the first place but
now i definitely don't want it you know what it is
it's dumb he's showing the piece of paper again no
i love it um wait just like just lastly because i
i don't like like keep you too long so i know
you haven't eaten and you're you're you're low
on um your blood levels are low bless you but
basically um today i saw that um a professor
and a finance professor at nyu said that
bitcoin crap school overpriced muriel rabini
how many years does it take to get a four-year
degree at nyu that's what i want to know how many
years to get a four-year degree at nyu nuriel
roubini go ahead leia what what do you mean
are you saying how like university can easily be
done in like one year is that what you're saying
are you saying people prolong it like if this
is an american thing i'm not dying to totally
and there's no video to this to this interview
is that what this is a audio only video uh
interview it's big okay so me using pictures isn't
totally insane no no no it's not totally insane
yeah yeah like i do have a nice amount of people
that follow the google and apple podcast version
um so that's cool um wait so before you run
because you've been such a gentleman coming on
my show last minute um what are you working on at
the moment and what are you doing let's get some
self promo just plug jason williams i am in an
intense bidding auction uh on christie's right now
for those of you who don't know that as an elegant
sophisticated british american i'm a lover of fine
art and wine and all kinds of sophisticated things
when you think of sophistication you should think
about the going parabolic guy i know i wear a
baseball cap and t-shirts almost all the time
but i'm highly sophisticated and so i'm trying to
buy this ferocious art um you know this is pride
month here in the united states i think and and
fuocious is amazing and so um i've got uh i got
a 350 000 bid on one piece and a 220 000 bid
on another piece i'm trying to yolo live life
there's one right behind me if uh right there is
a ferocious original and uh and that's a cantona
jersey the king manchester united eric the king
cantona and that's what i'm working on right now
the the auction's over in one hour and
31 minutes i'm watching it very closely
the bid is with me the bid is with me i love that
so you're just sitting on christy's buying stuff
bidding and trading on nfts right i'm bidding and
then trolling the people who i'm competing against
nice i like it it's a good day it's a good day
yeah and what are you doing the rest of the day
after this i have uh i'm working on this medical
thing building a bunch of primary care clinics
here in the united states um that i'll work
on this afternoon uh some strategy meetings
and then the gym uh yeah that's it i'm trying to
build these legs some people called me out they
said hey man you got a lot of arms but your legs
look a little weak so you know i'm gonna take that
so i've been in the gym for the last six months
crushing legs three times a week leia when you see
me you're gonna go what are you gonna say what do
you think you're watching i'm gonna give you a hug
to be honest you're gonna give me a hug and i'm
gonna say look at this guy's legs i hadn't seen
the legs like this two grand can we see can you
show us can you stand back and show us the legs
no i'm going to do a big reveal in el salvador
i've got very sport about very short shorts on
and i'm going to be walking with the president
up the mountain and people are going to be like
look at that guy's legs incredible legs this is
the next thing you need to be when you when you
do this you know tourism industry in el salvador
usually showing people volcanoes with muscly legs
and just walking around just being like this is
all that's me my thing's gone off and you need
to just be showing people the muscley legs the
volcanoes this is what bitcoin is about just sell
it you know it's gonna be like just let me get
paint the visual picture my legs ronaldo a volcano
bitcoin mining it's it's going to be a beautiful
beautiful thing the world will be a better place
climate change no one will even think about it
anymore they'll be like look at those calves
i love it i love it no the energy
is great you haven't eaten um no
honestly jason i'm a huge fan um so i want
to thank you so much for coming on my show
and i want to thank everyone for listening
um yeah i honestly think you're brilliant um
so thanks so much and enjoy working those legs
at the gym i'm on it thanks good to see you bye